tom mayhew has brought working-class
grit to the stages of the edinburgh
fringe for a decade
this french was the
the hardest for me to
afford
ever i've been coming up to the fringe
since
2012. we're living in this thing called
uh the cost of living crisis and if you
don't know what the cost of living
crisis is it's kind of like a
like a uh a long-awaited sequel to the
recession
it's kind of like a spin-off to the
credit crunch the rising cost of
everything from performance space to
accommodation means his days here may be
numbered so you do feel like is this a
place for us should we be here do you
want us here are you going to help us
get here and when you ask yourself that
question you do think am i going to be
here next year
for artists like tom who pay their way
and often lose money in the process the
promise of being discovered at one of
the world's best known arts festivals is
fading with the times
with half my life in immigrant exile
spent
in home is not the place one of two
shows by caroline-born scottish artist
annie george this year she explores her
creative roots a 30-year veteran of the
fringe she says minority voices are also
being squeezed out what seems to have
happened is that there's a narrowing of
the types of stories that we hear in
theater because of the type of people
who are doing it the lack of diversity
amongst the people who are being
centered
and so
theater is going to become irrelevant to
those audiences that come from those
communities
[Music]
the survival of the edinburgh festival
and the fringe in particular after a
near-death experience over the last
couple of years demonstrates that come
rain or shine or pandemic the show must
go on but the wider cost of living
crisis is feeding into a cost of
performing crisis with the art scene at
risk of being diminished forever
the life of a fringe unknown can be a
hand-to-mouth experience audiences are
increasingly drawn to big name
productions while the vital voices of
diversity are drowned out
the fringe as it was some say is no
longer
about money looks at the hopelessness of
young lives earning poverty wages an
increase in the nine pound an hour which
may not seem like much but it's not all
about money shown
what else is it about
turns out it is mostly about the money
jonah al jazeera edinburgh